she's a woman we want to ignore but she
keeps giving us more it's the queen of
Hades having boring chats with gutsy
ladies Hillary Clinton is back in a new
Apple TV Plus show called gutsy which
debuts next month it should make Jon
Stewart's ratings look like the last
episode of mash
she's hitting the road with daughter
Chelsea interviewing gutsy women along
the way insiders wonder if they'll skip
Wisconsin again
it features Mariska Hargitay Goldie Hawn
and Jane Goodall who's described Bill's
Behavior as Almost Human
the show explores life love heartache
despair overcoming devastating
challenges you know all this stuff Jamie
listall faces on a daily basis
in the new trailer Hillary opens up
about the gutsiest things she's ever
done and no it was not murdering Jeffrey
Epstein
you have a marriage that has been on
public display since the beginning you
said the gutsiest thing you ever did was
stay in your marriage that doesn't mean
that's right for everybody not right for
everybody kind of like Jamie's comedy
we're also getting a sneak peek of
Hillary trying to be fun with Kim
Kardashian they went head-to-head in a
legal quiz and much like her White House
run Hillary lost at that too
oh it was heartbreaking oh my gosh I was
also really intrigued by how well she
did I wanted to you know put the
spotlight on her not that she needs it
Kim would hit it in the mouth be like oh
wait no I don't hit it too so she has to
work on her reaction yeah
[Music]
yeah
correct we tried contacting Kim for a
comment but she mysteriously vanished
Without a Trace
well I gotta keep trying though but you
know it's a little mysterious cat would
you consider yourself a gutsy woman
if that's the scale
and like she's gonna she better not say
that to Jane Goodall who I love Jane
Goodall but like she's like I left my
whole life by behind to live with
chimpanzees because that's what I wanted
to do and she's like I stayed with a guy
who cheated on me a lot like one of
those is gutsier than the other I don't
get how it's gutsy I don't get how it's
gutsy at all you just didn't you did
nothing I don't I know that you probably
didn't get an invitation to be on the
show did you no I didn't well I'm gonna
try to fix that I would go they need to
fix it I just would like to see her be
as mean as she wants to be yes me too
like that that would be gutsy listen
Hillary you're a mean lady and that's
okay just be me we all know it yes I
agree we all know it
she might have won when she was talking
about Kim she's like yeah that's really
happy like guys I was like is there
something in there like holding this
smile up because you're not happy and
that's okay be mean right
yes Jamie what's the gutsiest thing
you've ever done uh maybe just coming on
here tonight with the jokes that are
before some of the jokes that have been
said uh
yeah her reaction time I like how the
excuse was like she doesn't have a good
it's not that she doesn't know about the
law yeah it's that her reaction time but
then again I'm thinking like she does
not have the best reaction time she is
still married to Bill
that's been a long time she should have
just pretended the buzzer was her email
delete button
you know bam how right is cat though
about it's just not that gutsy to say my
husband cheated on me I'm going to stay
married to the president of the United
States and I have political aspirations
like how gutsy if he had been a parking
lot attendant in Poughkeepsie
it would have been over right like how
gutsy is this yeah but she confessed to
that she goes it's not right for
everybody everybody's not right married
to the president it has the ability to
run on his name for said it and be
Secretary of State then run for the
presidency I think that's what she was
signaling it's like listen if they're
powerful and you can get something out
of it then stay with them the other
thing I just really cannot understand is
why is Chelsea on there I mean she's
just like her mother no personality no
Charisma she does she's nothing like a
father no it factor it's double Hillary
on One show and I just think that's bad
Jonathan is this Hillary trying to be
more relatable and get a lot of eyeballs
on Apple TV so if you can run again as
soon as you have to say I'm going to try
to be more relatable like you fall into
the very very problem that cat brought
out like just be yourself do you think
it comes down it comes down down to
authenticity right because and the
reason why there's no authenticity here
is she says it was gazi of me to stay
with Bill yeah it is hard and gutsy to
stay with someone once you've decided to
do that for the right reasons but at the
same time then she's criticizing and
like demeaning the very women yeah like
who who were abused by Bill right and so
there is the lack of authenticity it's
the lack of leadership it's a lack of
trust like these people are not
trustworthy why would we vote for them
and why is it that these are the very
best people in our country like for to
lead right I I really hope there's a new
generation of authentic people I don't
have to be perfect but be authentic I
would watch a show where Hillary just
sends back food at a diner
over and over he's so pissed off and
just yelling at him yeah I watch that
all day and she'd take the hot sauce out
of it yeah exactly she just sends it
back I don't know more authentic would
be so being herself [ __ ] like she would
order a very very expensive bottle of
wine
oh no no you know she's never ordered
assuming that was the right time she
would not be at a diner let's be
honestly went to the diner as part of
the show she was like oh she sees her
schedule the night before it's like oh
the diner coming up gen Z's future plans
including amassing horrors of fans
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else